[Music]
welcome back now to the issue of the day
the very latest from the poorest
wideopen Southern border with a record
302,000 illegal migrants encountered at
the southern Border in December alone
president Trump just a moment ago
telling me in an exclusive interview his
plan to solve the crisis at the border
will include deportation of most of the
10 million illegals already here after
they entered illegally under the Biden
Administration joining me right now with
reaction is governor of Texas Greg
Abbott Governor thanks very much for
joining us this morning your reaction to
what you heard from president
Trump listen the the the president
outlined uh his two top priorities which
are the top priorities across the United
States uh one is to crack down on
illegal immigration and this is more
than rhetoric on his part he has a
proven record about what he did when he
was president remember when he was
president uh he implemented four
policies that led to the lowest illegal
border crossings in 40 years and the
second thing he talked about uh was
drilling for more energy this is
important because it connects to the
economy in the United States of America
and biomics inflation First America can
should be energy independent second most
importantly what Joe Biden is doing by
his policies he's trying to destroy the
jobs of hardworking men and women in the
energy sector who depend upon producing
energy for a paycheck and also because
of Joe Biden's policies is leading to an
increase in the of the pump that
Americans are so angry about so
president Trump is honing in on the top
two issues affecting Americans yeah and
they affect Texas uh first before the
rest of the country right I mean look
just the other day last week President
Biden cancelled all of those LNG
contracts he wants to uh look at the way
the federal government approaches those
contracts what kind of an impact is that
having on Texas well it's going to be
extraordinary te Texas is a leading LG
exporter for one but for another
countries across the globe count on us
for energy ranging from the European
region that that if they don't get our
LNG they may have to once again rely
upon Russia uh for their natural gas
supplies also there's other countries
like uh India and other countries across
the globe where if they do not get our
LG they may have to revert back to using
coal which obviously provides more air
pollution than natural gas does and so I
got to tell you uh the decision by Joe
Biden literally makes no sense what
whatsoever it harms the people that he's
trying to connect with uh but also it
harms jobs in the United States of
America and hinders our energy
Independence well also questionable is
the the decision to allow 8 to 10
million illegals from across the world
into America uh and then give them court
dates 10 years later um want to get your
take on the assessment at the border
today you know you've got a border trip
coming up you are hosting several
Governors from across the country at the
southern border today correct correct
can you tell us about it sure that's
correct Maria more than half of the
governors are now joined together uh in
support of a very important proposition
and that is we are guaranteed by the
United States Constitution the right of
self-defense uh if States face imminent
harm or Invasion Texas obviously is
facing both an imminent harm uh as well
as an invasion and so these Governors
are rallying around Texas to support our
ongoing right to
selfdefense uh and and the deployment of
this razor wire that has led to uh a a
massive reduction in inflow Maria get
this uh the area where we uh have have
occupied this park in Eagle Pass Texas
that we put up the razor wire uh there
used to be 3,000 or 4,000 people
crossing that area a day uh for the past
three days we've averaged just three
people crossing that area the point is
if we put up resistance we show that we
can secure the Border Joe Biden should
not be stopping that yeah let me get
your take on what's going on in New York
we understand now New York is going to
be spending $53 million uh to come up
with prepaid credit cards for the
illegal migrants uh what do you think's
behind this why do they need prepaid
credit
cards uh it it sounds like insanity is
behind it because it it really is is
offensive this maybe the most
reprehensible thing that I've seen take
place over the past 48 Hours when you
when you see police officers in New York
City being beaten by illegal immigrants
uh in this country who should not be in
the country in the first place and then
after they engage in this crime against
a law enforcement law enforcement
officer they are let loose back out onto
the streets what's going on in New York
is outrageous and Americans across the
entire country are angry not just about
what's going on in New York but the
underlying cause for it which is Joe
Biden's open border policies and and why
do you think Joe Biden has this open
border policy what is your thinking in
terms of why he continues to do this in
the last two weeks the president said
he's known that the border is not secure
he's known it for 10 years he said he
says he doesn't have the power even
though on day one he walked into the
Oval Office and reversed all of
President Trump's security at the
border yeah so you you make a very
important point and and that is you know
Biden says he needs Congress uh to give
him the power to do whatever he needs to
do to secure the border the fact is as
we all saw from what president Trump did
the president of the United States has
the power I must emphasize this uh there
is an obligation there are laws in the
United States uh that require the
president to deny illegal entry of any
illegal immigrant and then if they do
get into the United States he has a
legal obligation to detain those illegal
immigrants Joe Biden is failing at both
of those duties and that's exactly what
gives Texas the authority
to make sure that we can step up and
secure our own border and protect our
own State through self-defense Governor
we'll be watching your efforts to secure
the Border in Texas and for America we
so appreciate your time this morning
thank you sir thank you Maria I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis